[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 ce qu'il faut retenir
de l'actualité locale voici les titres
de ce mercredi 5 février
filmer une scène d'accident au travers
d'un appel vidéo pour aider rapidement
les services de secours dans leur
diagnostic le principe d'urgent times
dont la start up est basée à montigny le
bretonneux le service testé actuellement
devraient être utilisés pour les jo de
2024 à montigny le bretonneux justement
trois listes sont pour le moment
candidate aux municipales m pour
alternative ini monteyne écologique et
solidaire sera menée par le conseiller
municipal d'opposition y vient gasc en
binôme avec caroline ce chaos la page
dédiée au scrutin à la fin de cette
édition
et puis retour sur la troisième édition
de sensations en scène la radio à de
saint quentin en yvelines a pris une
nouvelle fois hier place au théâtre de
fontenay-le-fleury deux heures
d'émission en live avec la présence
notamment de l'animateur magloire dans
cette édition présentation également de
l'enquète à la ferme qui sera mené à la
bergerie nationale pendant les vacances
d'hiver sauver des vies avoir un
diagnostic plus fiable en améliorant la
prise en charge des patients par les
services de secours grâce à la vidéo de
son téléphone c'est l'objectif d'urgent
times une stat une start up basée à
montigny le bretonneux trois personnes
l'ont créée en collaboration avec le
samu et des yvelines manon varaldo s'est
rendu aux cubes pour rencontrer son
dirigeant tout part de son expérience
personnelle suite un accident de moto
anthony table you a frôlé la paralysie à
vie suite à un mauvais diagnostic quand
les pompiers sont arrivés ils se sont
rendus compte qu'ils avaient mal évalué
début gravité qu'elle même les pompiers
ont fait ou attirant et m'ont dit bon
écoute on n'avait pas compris que
c'était henry n'a aussi entre grave
c'était le conducteur de la voiture qui
avait renversé qui avait appelé qui
avait fait la meilleure description
possible et les poupées m'ont dit si on
avait su on aurait envoyé une équipe
médicalisée
donc là on peut rien faire pour toi
juste servait dans mon travail à
l'hôpital si les pompes y avait plus me
voir avant de
je n'aurais pas frôlé cette paralysie
avis anthony taburiaux a eu le déclic
ray et urgente time pour améliorer le
diagnostic le but localiser les victimes
en quelques secondes et permettre au
samu d'activer la caméra des
particuliers et mettre fin aux appels
abusifs
depuis trois ans son équipe a co
développé la solution avec le samu 78ème
en tant que ça mais je veux dire ok je
vois que votre caméra pour ce qui se
passe donc comment comment ça va se
faire je vous envoyez un lien par sms
vous vous trompez pas les niveaux mais
tu es en haut parleurs devrait baisser
mais si vous cliquez sur le lien et je
vais voir ce que vous voyez tout
l'intérêt du fait qu'ils aient pas coupé
la ligne c'est que si jamais la vidéo ne
marche pas pour une raison quelconque
ce qui paraît il n'y a pas de bande
passante n'ya pas d'internet on n'a pas
coupé le son le futur trentenaire et son
équipe ont gagné le prix smart paris
2024 urgente time sera utilisée pour les
jeux olympiques de 2024
ça permettra aussi vous être en êtres
entre les mets plus décontracté ou plus
sur un an des encaisses il y avait un
vent moyen problème où je vois quelque
chose je sais que je pourrai montrer je
vais sur eure on mettra aussi un
traducteur en direct la ministre de la
santé agnès buzyn bien de décidé de
subventionner les appels vidéo dans les
samu à hauteur de 15 millions d'euros
entre 2020 et 2022 urgent times est
actuellement testé par le samu de nantes
dans l'actualité le vote hier du budget
commun des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine les deux collectivités
réunies en établissement public
interdépartemental honte entériné pour
l'année 2020 et les yvelines
participeront à hauteur de 6 millions
d'euros dans les crédits de
fonctionnement de l'entité parmi les
principales dépenses de le pays 14,3
millions d'euros pour l'entretien et des
routes départementales plus d'un million
d'euros en faveur de l'archéologie
préventive ou encore 117 1000 euros sur
le volet adoption l établissement a été
créé pour rappel en février 2016 volonté
et des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
d'aller vers une fusion est d'ailleurs
nouvelle étape dans ce processus le
lancement à partir de demain jeudi d'une
concertation citoyenne en ligne pour les
trois millions d'habitants des deux
départements est la question pour ou
contre la fusion ne sera pas posée mais
la démarche a pour but est d'informer
sur les enjeux est également de
permettre aux yvelinois et alto
séquanais de s'exprimer autour de six
thèmes et développement économique
emploi et innovation mobile
c'est environnement et cadre de vie
solidarité et ruralité culture et
patrimoine et enfin la scène tout juste
deux mois qu'a commencé la grève contre
la réforme des retraites le texte contre
7 sur cette réforme sera bien en
première lecture à partir du 17 février
à l'assemblée nationale des
mobilisations se poursuivent toutefois
dans le département des yvelines une
retraite aux flambeaux et par exemple
programmé ce soir à rambouillet devant
le lycée basse quand d'autres actions
également dont nous parlerons dans notre
édition du journal de demain jeudi
et depuis le mois de novembre radio
sensations se met en scène une fois par
mois deux heures d'émission en live
interview et quiz pour cette troisième
édition de sensations en scène nous
avons assisté à la soirée au théâtre de
fontenay le fleury retour avec marylène
yapi chine cette fois une scène de
théâtre remplace le studio de radio pour
cette soirée spéciale que propose radio
sensations depuis le mois de novembre
deux heures d'antenne sur les six
fréquences de la station objectif
présenter de jeunes talents pour une
émission animée par un autre jeune
talent passionné je fais de la radio
depuis j'ai 11 ans bah je suis passé de
ma chambre à des webradios puis des
radios locales maintenant sur la
sensation que c'est un vrai plaisir de
faire partie de cette aventure être
continué à divulguer plein de culture et
notamment dans les blocs notre culture
de sensations tous les jours au
programme de la musique en live suivez
d'interviews pour découvrir les artistes
leur univers je vais chanter
deux de mes singles qui se rendent dans
le paix qui va sortir avant l'été est
également une chanson que je chante en
trio avec des membres de ma famille le
groupe s'appelle en dessous je chante
avec mon petit frère et ma fille de 17
ans nelly ns
[Musique]
et un invité spécial l'animateur de
télévision magloire a accompagné
auditeurs et spectateurs tout au long de
la soirée
pourquoi être venu ce soir parce qu'ils
veulent moi yvelines parce que les
yvelines sont chers à mon coeur parce
que c'est une nouvelle expérience et que
figurez vous que je ne refuse jamais une
nouvelle expérience
la soirée s'est terminée par un militant
dj nantais pourrait écouter l'émission
le podcast est disponible sur le site
internet de la radio
prochain rendez-vous pour sensation en
scène le 17 mars à versailles elle va
subir une cure de jouvence l'église
notre dame sera rénové la municipalité a
octroyé une enveloppe de 3 5 millions
d'euros pour lancer une première phase
de travaux elle va concerner la façade
principale la chapelle du sacré-coeur et
le grand orgue l'édifice datant du xviie
siècle oeuvres de jules hardouin mansart
souffre de sa vétusté
c'est de l'église notre dame qui est
parti le 4 mai 1789 est la procession
inaugurale des états généraux est les
vacances d'hiver commencent ce vendredi
soir en ile-de-france forcément des
animations qui vont animer à toutes les
vacances d'hiver dans les yvelines à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet par
exemple on vous propose de mener une
enquête à la ferme et on en parle avec
frédéric brieuc bonsoir en soit vous
êtes le responsable de la ferme
pédagogique à la bergerie nationale si
on peut déjà pitcher cette animation
c'est une enquête qui est lancée il ya
une menace qui plane sur la bergerie
nationale c'est ça exactement ça voilà
l'ex l'exploitation de la bergerie
nationale est en agroécologie sinaï des
cultures qui est respectueuse de
l'environnement donc l'objectif c'est
d'expliquer une des notions importantes
c'est le bien-être animal
donc effectivement 1
un voleur est passé à la bergerie pour
dérober un manuel qui contient tout le
tout le processus pour faire en sorte
que nos animaux soient en bonne santé
donc du coup les enfants vont devoir
passer dans différents bâtiments pour
effectivement résoudre différentes
différentes énigmes pour faire en sorte
que nos animaux retrouvent finalement
les notions de bien-être animal
ça veut dire que sur les objets qui font
part d'un un jeu pour avoir aussi un
côté ludique expliquer des choses
voilà un enfant c'est vrai que c'est pas
des choses évidentes d'expliquer ce que
c'est que l'agro écologie ou
l'agriculture biologique donc finalement
nous avons décidé de rendre acteurs
l'enfant accompagnée de ses parents ou
de ses grands-parents et du coup les
enfants sont à lui accueilli dans un
bureau ou un commissaire va les mettre
en situation finalement en leur
expliquant le problème à résoudre
ensuite ils partent pendant une heure
sur l'exploitation qui est quand même
assez grande ils vont visiter le
bâtiment des moutons le bâtiment des
vaches la basse cour et les bâtiments
des chevaux sans oublier le labyrinthe
végétal et devront dans ces différents
lieux résoudre finalement une partie de
l' enquête et l'ensemble de ses
résolutions permettront à la fin de
savoir qui est le coupable c'est un peu
sur le principe vous savez du jeu qui
est ce nous qui a animé à récupérer dans
chaque dans chaque lieu et l'ensemble de
ces énigmes permettra à l'enfant de
trouver le bon coupable avec le but on
l'a compris d'informer aussi l'enfance a
fait partie des missions de la bergerie
nationale d'informer le public
voilà finalement la bergerie ses cinq
missions donc moi je m'occupe d'une
démission qui s'appelle animations et
territoires mais il ya aussi une mission
qui est plus en lien avec la formation
une mission qui est plus en lien avec
l'appui et l'innovation pour tous les
futurs créateurs de ferme
d'exploitations agricoles et il ya eu
aussi une mission de d'élevage et enfin
une mission qui en lien avec avec le
patrimoine mais effectivement mon
travail et moi c'est d'accueillir le
public on accueille à peu près cent
mille personnes par an que ce soit des
scolaires des centres de loisirs ou des
personnes dans le cadre
un peu familier individuel et dans tous
les cas le maître mot reste
l'agriculture biologique d'expliquer un
petit peu toutes ces notions qui sont
parfois difficiles à comprendre
alors cette enquête allait proposer
l'après midi de 14 heures à 16 heures il
y aussi d'autres animations qui sont
proposées autour autour de cette enquête
finalement le commissaire est présent de
14 à 16 heures parce qu'à un moment il
faut aussi s'arrêter étant donné qu'on
est avant tout une exploitation agricole
il faut aussi s'occuper des animaux donc
jusqu'à on va dire 16 heures on
accueille les derniers enfants vont ils
peuvent mener l enquête jusqu'à 17
heures et à partir de 17 heures c'est
finalement l'activité de l'art de
l'exploitation qui revient avec les
soins aux animaux la traite des vaches
des activités animalière cette fois ci
qui ne seront punis en lien avec la
thématique des vacances et donc cette
enquête elle sera proposé pendant toutes
les tous les jours de ces vacances
d'hiver tu sais du premier jour aux
derniers jours on trouve ça important
parce qu'effectivement on se rend bien
compte que tout le monde ne peut pas
venir sur une ou deux fois et on se rend
aussi compte que pas mal de parents
reviennent avec leurs enfants ou c'est
le l'enfant qui est venu avec ses grands
parents qu'il reviendra et que c'est
avec ses parents et c'est ça qui est
plutôt sympa on a réussi finalement à
créer beaucoup de fidélité dévoile à des
enfants qui reviennent plusieurs fois
parce qu'ils n'ont pas forcément réussi
à tout faire sur le sur le temps donné
on l'a compris c'est une activité qui
s'adresse aux familles aux enfants mais
aussi à leurs parents et leurs
grands-parents pourquoi pas pour venir
laisse qu'une inscription est nécessaire
on peut venir directement sur place
on peut venir directement et la
possibilité de réserver en amont sur le
site de la bergerie mais ce n'est pas
une obligation voilà il faut venir sur
place idéalement d'aidé entre 14h et un
petit 15 heures si on veut vraiment
pouvoir profiter de l'ensemble de l'
enquête mais c'est ouvert voilà tous les
jours à partir de à partir de 15h et
suite à ça effectivement il ya la petite
ax animation animalière et on peut finir
par un petit goûter dans l'espace de
mérinos cassé venez à lenquête venez
mené l enquête à la bergerie nationale
c'est du 8 au 23 février sur ce lieu les
informations à retrouver bien sûr sur le
site internet de la bergerie nationale
merci frédéric brieuc s'est présenté
cette animation au plateau il rappelle
que vous êtes est le responsable de la
ferme pédagogique de la bergerie
nationale à voisins le bretonneux aussi
une enquête était à résoudre le week-end
dernier la compagnie tisseur de songes
organiser une murder party à la salle de
la tour et est le lieu d'un crime celui
d'un pianiste russe nicolas landry et
mélanie poquet on peut aussi mener l
enquête suisse et nous meurtres les avis
divergent mais une chose est sûre le
grands concertistes alexei zhamnov qui
ne sera pas sa représentation de ce soir
il leur faut donc ok neuf suspects sont
identifiés et à ce moment là il a appris
que de la personne qui devait lui
tourner les pages
vous pouvez pas venir michael ii nièvre
était la doublure du pianiste il assuré
les représentations avant et après les
spectacles et les séances de dédicaces
des liens très professionnelle alors au
début ça se passait très bien entre nous
et puis petit à petit on peut dire que
ça s'est un petit peu dégradé la
situation s'est tendue entre nous une
enquête de deux heures pour identifier
les 50 indice et des interrogatoires
comme celui d'olivia bertin ancien
pianiste est aujourd'hui critique
musical moi ma certitude c'est que c'est
un suicide parce que je sais et j'ai
écrit dans un article qu'il était malade
à l'organisation de cette lourdeur
partie la compagnie tisseur de songer
l'association tout ce qu il y plusieurs
semaines de création pour aboutir ce
cluedo grandeur nature évidemment il ya
eu un meurtre et les participants
doivent trouver qui est le coupable ou
la coupable
mais le fond de l'histoire c'est que
nous on écrit toute une histoire on a
travaillé des personnages on écrit un
fil narratif un axe est donc en fait on
découvre toute une histoire et on est
vraiment entre le jeu entre plus de
grandeur nature et le spectacle 200
participants ont relevé le défi
découvert la vérité pour tv 78 le
mystère reste entier
comme tous les mercredis direction les
cinémas pour connaître la programmation
des salles de notre territoire ce soir
c'est à l'espace philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois que nous nous rendons
les films à l'affiché au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
cette semaine dans les salles de
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois nous vous proposons une
semaine de cinéma à la française puisque
nous aurons quatre films en tous genres
français avec deux comédies le lion je
suis le dr tardy commencé par me dire
comment vous appelez et au milan nom de
code le lit où les hommes il en existe
pas si la couverture des arbitres ou
quoi et l'esprit de famille intel a tapé
trop con je sais que je tombe un
thriller les traducteurs et un film
d'animation samsam en sortie nationale à
partir de 3 ans pour les enfants le
thriller réalisé par régis roinsard avec
lambert wilson
les traducteurs nous raconte l'histoire
de neuf traducteur enfermé dans une
luxueuse demeure afin de traduire le
dernier tome d'un très célèbre roman
internationale mais lorsque les dix
premières pages du roman sont publiés
sur internet et qu'un pirate menace de
dévoiler la suite si on ne lui reverse
pas une rançon colossal une question
devient obsédante qui est le coupable
un scénario palpitant qui vous fera
frémir d'inquiétude
ce thriller les traducteurs est fait
pour vous à retrouver nous donc à
l'espace philippe noiret
[Musique]
allez on termine ce journal à présent
par la page dédiée aux élections
municipales et j'accueille karolinska au
bon soir soir vous êtes candidate à
montigny le bretonneux sur la liste mm
pour alternative ni monteyne écologique
et citoyenne la tête de liste et vivien
gasc actuel conseiller municipal
d'opposition dans la commune mais c'est
bien un duo vous composer avec lui que
vous souhaitez mettre en avant pourquoi
mais la liste m c'est un collectif qui
existe depuis le début de l'année
dernière et depuis le mois de septembre
en oeuvre ensemble on fait les
assemblées citoyennes pour élaborer le
programme et il ne semblait pas
approprié d'avoir une seule personne qui
représentait tout le collectif
donc on a fait le choix d'un binôme et
donc c'est le binôme qui est mis en
avant sur toute la communication qui est
là pour présenter le programme aux
habitants tout le collectif est avec
nous pour présenter le programme et
c'est vraiment cette force là qu'on a
voulu mettre en avant et je rectifie
juste pardon parce que j'ai dit que
c'était écologique et citoyenne c'est
écologique et solidaire m voilà dans
cette liste mais du coup si vous êtes
élu y aura bien un seul maire qui sera
en poste
alors après il y aura un seul maire en
poste mais notre objectif c'est que le
premier adjoint
la première adjointe en l'occurrence
soit autant investi dans le rôle que le
maire qui suivent les dossiers soient
suivies à deux et qu'on puisse
prendre le rôle l'un de l'autre il y en
a toujours un qui a la délégation qui
est la responsabilité mais après sur des
dossiers on peut partager la responsable
des fonctions partager le temps surtout
qui est que ce soit pas une seule
personne qui gère la ville comme c'est
le cas un peu partout alors votre liste
aurait pu s'allier à une autre menée par
pierre déjean une candidature qui
revendiquait à gauche pourquoi les
discussions n'ont pas abouti avec pierre
des gens ça n'a pas abouti mascella la
vision de ce qu'on a envie de faire
voyez nous c'est un collectif qui
fonctionne n'est pas forcément à une
seule personne et ça ça finalement pas
coller on peut le regretter
parce que nos idées
ce sont parfois les mêmes mais vraiment
sur le côté démocratie participative
on va beaucoup plus loin sur la
transition écologique on est beaucoup
plus innovant en fait et ça ça n'a pas
marché pour ms que la sensibilité et
aussi à gauche c'est une candidature
plurielle finalement c'est une
candidature plurielle mais on se
revendique pas d'être à gauche comme à
droite mais on n'est plus à l'heure où
il faut s'opposer
il faut s'unir pour construire la ville
de demain il ya beaucoup d'urgences
il ya des crises climatiques et crise
sociale et crise économique il faut
qu'on aille qu'on avance qu'on aille de
l'avant et qu'on passe au delà de ces
idées de parti politique et donc nous on
est sans étiquette
on a des valeurs qui sont l'écologie la
démocratie participative la solidarité
qui se retrouve dans ses valeurs peut
nous rejoindre pour travailler alors le
programme parlons-en il a été construit
après une phase de concertation vous
avez rencontré lésigny mon teint pour
construire vos priorités pour s'en
passer ça donc depuis le mois de
septembre
on a fait des ateliers porteurs de
paroles où on était dans les places de
montigny dans les quartiers pour
discuter avec les gens savoir quelles
étaient leurs ressentis de la ville on a
construit fait des ateliers de
l'assemblée citoyenne
on en a fait quatre pour construire ce
programme en fait on a eu des idées les
citoyens à la porte d'autres et ensemble
qu'est ce qu'on priorise qu'est ce qui
est important qu est-ce qui est pas
important sur quoi la mairie peut agir
c'est tout ça qui s'est fait ensemble et
du coup on a plus de 100 propositions
pour
dynamiser la ville détaillé ses 100
propositions en tout cas on va parler de
trois axes prioritaires
vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
démocratie participative c'est
d'ailleurs l'une de ses trois priorités
que vous exposez pour le programme
comment la mettre en place
à montigny le bretonneux qu'est ce que
vous entendez par démocratie
participative juste mais pour nous la
démocratie participative c'est que les
citoyens puissent s'impliquer dans la
vie de la commune pas juste en allant
choisir leurs élus
mais en étant force de proposition on va
mettre en place des groupes d'action
projet donc quand on fait un projet on
va appeler les habitants
on va faire intervenir des experts faire
tout un groupe qui fonctionne qui
communiquent qui co construit le projet
c'est pas la mairie qui vient qui va
dire j'impose ça je veux faire ça non
les habitants
c'est quoi votre ressenti nous refaire
ce projet là comment vous le voyez nous
on a nos exigences d'éthique d'écologie
de solidarité qui viennent avec
mais comment on peut faire que tout ça
fonctionne ensemble c'est à dire aussi
que les projets iront forcément moins
vite ou au contraire ils seront plus
réfléchi mais ils vont forcément être
plus réfléchi
est-ce que ça va aller moins vite pas
forcément parce que le temps de
conception de co construction va
peut-être plus long mais du coup le
projet sera bien pensée on n'aura plus
besoin de faire des réajustements à la
fin qui allonge les projets alors une
autre priorité pardon c'est la
transition écologique
comment à l'échelle d'une commune on
peut mettre en place des actions
justement en faveur de cette transit
transition écologique mais il ya
énormément de choses à faire
déjà la mairie se doit d'être exemplaire
on veut que les bâtiments soient
vraiment économes en énergie qui soit
mieux isolés que l'électricité soit soit
mieux penser qu'ils soient producteurs
d'énergie solaire aussi pourquoi pas
donc c'est un axe après c'est aussi
quand on est dans nos services ben
comment on peut être tendre vers le zéro
déchet par exemple produire moins de
déchets des véhicules de la flotte de la
mairie ben comment on peut les repenser
et ce qu'on peut mettre par exemple des
trottinettes électriques quand on veut
se déplacer d'une école à une autre
au lieu de prendre a forcément une
voiture c'est de repenser un peu tout
tout ce que fait la mairie pour voir
comment on peut réduire l'empreinte
carbone de la vie donc plusieurs pistes
évoquées alors la dernière priorité
c'est de la solidarité le vivre ensemble
quel type de proposition vous pouvez
faire sur sur cet axe allant sur la
solidarité ça nous tient beaucoup à
coeur de développer l'insertion par
exemple que dans les antres pour les
entreprises qui sont sollicités par la
mairie pour intervenir sur tous les
projets on met une clause d'insertion
dans les marchés publics de même qu'on
va mettre des clauses écologique il faut
qu'il y ait une clause d'insertion
alors ces élections municipales aussi je
le précise il y aura également des
élections communautaire on élit nos
conseillers municipaux mais aussi les
ailes et conseiller communautaire votre
regard sur le travail les liens entre
montigny le bretonneux et
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines montigny-le-bretonneux qui est
forcément une ville centrale dans cette
agglomération il ya notamment ce projet
d'hyper centre qui est en tout cas de
l'actualité du moment quel est le regard
vous portez
mais ce travail ben en tant que
citoyenne je participe à la concertation
je suis allé aux ateliers il y en a fin
février
moi je trouve ça génial de pouvoir
mettre les habitants au coeur de la
concertation au coeur de la conception
après il faut voir nous ce qu'on
aimerait c'est que là le projet puisse
entrer dans 21e siècle on parle vraiment
d'écologie mais que ce soit à la base on
vous parlait de circulations douces ont
réfléchi aux matériaux qu'on utilise
on va repenser toutes les circulations
voiture on va voir quels sont les usages
aussi de la ville parce que c'est un
quartier que je pratique parce que c'est
le mien où on n'a pas de lieu de vie
donc c'est pour nous c'est fondamental
que ce soit fait vraiment concertation
avec les habitants et qu'on remette de
la verdure qu'on remette du lien que
tout ça fonctionne ensemble
après si justin pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas hyper sentent que il
s'agit du quartier 1 qui est autour de
la gare sncf de saint quentin en
yvelines
une dernière question vos prochains
rendez vous de campagne mais ce soir on
a une réunion publique ce mercredi soir
à la maison de quartier louis jouvet
après c'est le 27 février
on serait en réunion publique à la
maison de quartier malraux et le 10 mars
à la salle jacques brel
merci karolinska aux candidates de la
liste m
alternative innovante n écologique et
solidaire
et je précise qu à montigny le
bretonneux deux autres listes sont
également candidates celle menée par
pierre déjean montigny solidarité 2020
et la liste également de laurens merker
candidat de la majorité sortante
iny monteyne direction la verrière pour
clore cette édition afin de connaître
les enjeux des élections municipales
dans la commune emploie désertification
médicale rénovation urbaine et grands
projets ont fait le point avec nicolas
dans deux communes historique de la
ville nouvelle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la verrière
compte plus de 6000 habitants une ville
touchée par des problématiques sociales
un taux de chômage de 16 % le taux de
pauvreté atteint près de 24% l'insertion
et l'emploi des verrières watts de
sujets sur lesquels la future majorité
pourra agir en collaboration avec
d'autres collectivités
un sujet lié à l'éducation et la
scolarité dès le plus jeune âge la lutte
contre la délinquance est aussi un sujet
pris en compte par les candidats la
verrière touchée aussi par le phénomène
de désert médical le manque de médecins
et de professionnels de santé sur la
commune pose des difficultés d'accès aux
soins des projets d'aménagement sur la
ville d'abord la rénovation du quartier
du bois de l'étang un sujet qui divise
d'un côté une rénovation sur les
bâtiments existants
de l'autre une destruction
reconstruction partielle de certains
immeubles autres quartiers de la
verrière orly parc concerné par
plusieurs projets d'aménagement
autre projet d'urbanisation
intercommunale menée conjointement avec
saint quentin en yvelines le projet
urbain gare bécane 1800 logements une
zone d'activité économique et un pôle de
transport multimodal
juste à côté le carrefour de la malle me
donne attendu pour 2026 le réaménagement
du site prévoit son enfouissement la
verrière maurepas et coignières
actuellement séparés par la nationale 10
seront reliés
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant nouveau
numéro du 7 8 sociétés à quoi ressemble
la vie de châtelain dans les yvelines le
thème abordé ce soir sur un territoire
forcément où il ya beaucoup de châteaux
et belles soirées sur tv 78
[Musique]